محبوسين ضلنا قاعدين بالخيام محبوسين يعني
مكان ضق يعني الحمامات يعني فيش حمامات
ويعني بطلت اقرب بطلت ولا شي اسوي وصرت
ضلني خايف واشوف الرعب قصف اللي جنبينا
والله عملتها على حالي يعني وحياه ربي خفت
كنت مبسوطه كن نلعب را ك نلعب شنار ك نلعب
حز ونرسم وندرس يعني كنا كيفين ز الحرب
بطنا نلعب ولا شي صيرنا نقعد بالخير
[موسيقى]
محبوسين نفسي يصير وقف اطلاق نار نبطل
نشوف الصواريخ بتنزل قدامنا انا نفسي ارجع
على المدرسه نفسي اكون حر اعيش بامان بين
الدور والناس نفسي اشوف زملائي اللي
استشهدوا نفسي اشوف دارنا اللي راحت ان
حرقوا والناس ماتوا نفسي ارجع على المدرسه
اقرا ندرس نلعب مع
زملائنا ونلعب ونعيش ونكون بامان فيشان
بصف ه اول امبارح قبل اسبوعين قصفوا هنا
طلعوا منها شهداء 15 شهيد و 20
شهيد كنا حياتنا نعبي مي اه ونجيب حطب
عشان نولع للحمام نتحمم وكنا
للعجين انا كنت
بالمدرسه كنت العب مع اصحابي وكنت
ادرس
تتب الحرب هذه ما جابتنا غير وغير الهجره
ما عمرنا تهجرنا في الحروب الا هذه الحرب
الحرب هذه كانت اقوى حرب في الحروب اللي ا
جتنا كلها اول مره نشوف نقعد هيك يعني في
خيم وشفنا المت في عينينا الموت شفناه في
عينينا احنا مش عايشين حياتنا غير في
المدارس وفي المخيمات بعد الحرب اتمنى انه
يكون موجودين الاساس واتمنى انه يكون موجو
مدارس بس حتقعد المدارس كثير كثير سنين
لما تتعمر من كثر من كثر النازحين اللي
كانوا
فيها احنا هلقيت عشنا عشنا الحرب كيف خوف
وزلل
وصوت صوت كثير
بخوف وكل قرايبنا
مستشهدين نعرفش نلعب ولا نبسط ولا نروح
نلعب كوره ولا نسكر ولا شي ولا نطلع على
البلد على غزه ولا شي نسنا نوقف الحرب
ونرجع على المدارس نشوف الابلات
والازيه ونجر ونلعب نطلع على
الفرسه من غزه للجنوب من خانون لرفح يعني
احنا بنضل نتنقل يعني تعبنا واحنا بنتن قل
من كل من كل مكان فقدنا الاتصال في ابويا
وتستشهد عمي ودارنا انصفت احنا وامي كمان
استشهدت انا يعني كنت قبل الحرب في
المدرسه انا كنت في الصف الثامن كنت ادرس
يعني واجيب علامات عاليه في الامتحانات
فبعد جت الحرب وانقطع عن المدرسه كلها
وانا اشتقت لها يعني المدرسه وراحوا كل
الامتحانات
وخلصوا